[MUSIC PLAYING]
AQEEL PHILLIPS: The Princeton
University Rock Ensemble
is the first and only rock
cover group on campus.
We are a home for
musicians who haven't
found a place in jazz
or classical collectives
on campus,
so really unique in
music that we play.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATIE FRORER: I've never
been in a rock band before.
It's something that
I had wanted to do.
I've had like different
levels of vocal training,
in like operatic soprano and
like musical theater and pop
and rock, but I've never
been able to then pursue
the pop and rock side
as much as I'd like.
So this has been really cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AQEEL PHILLIPS:
PURE is currently
a group comprised
of undergraduates,
spanning most of the
disciplines in the school.
We have a good number
of STEM students,
a good number of
humanities  students,
so we're all over the place.
JOSHUA MURRAY: It's
fantastic meeting
all these different people,
because while you have this
one common theme, which
is the music you
like, they bring
in ideas from all across
different areas of campus
that you wouldn't be
exposed to otherwise.
FIORA ELBERS-TIBBITTS:
Being part of PURE
is a lot more of a
social experience
than I had anticipated.
We'll come together to
rehearse, anticipating an hour,
and then we'll end up
staying and talking
for another 45 minutes,
wandering over to dinner.
And it becomes a
four-hour excursion.
It feels like a study break as
much as it does a rehearsal.
BRANDON TAN: PURE is
a really good break,
honestly from academics
just because I
can't be studying all the time.
So it's really good
to have something else
productive to do besides work.
And it's just a good way
to relieve stress too,
just bang on the drum set and
just getting together friends.
There's nothing else as fun as
playing music, in my opinion.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID EXUME: I remember visiting
Princeton University when
I was in high school
and being like,
I want to play on
like that stage
in like Richardson in
like Frist theater.
But now I'm like
playing in Frist theater
and it's a lot of fun.
Everybody has a lot of
energy and people are always
like upstairs like cheering
us on, giving us feedback.
I feel very whole
when I'm on stage.
As somebody who doesn't
like talking a whole lot,
it feels great to step out
of my skin for a little bit.
AQEEL PHILLIPS:
My favorite thing
about like playing an
instrument, especially
in a group like this,
is just like getting
to be on stage like
with your friends,
you know, like
collaborating with them,
like you know, being down here,
like rehearsing with them.
I just like love all of it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]